c'était donc le documentaire il décroche
des jeunes dans la tourmente un
documentaire auquel vous pouvez réagir
sur les réseaux sociaux et notre hashtag
docudébat ce documentaire a été réalisé
par jean-vacpellerin qui est avec nous
ce soir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à
vos côté Bernard gerers bonsoir vous
êtes enseignant cofondateur de
l'association la bouture et du klept
collège et lycée élitaire pour tous vous
êtes aussi directeur du centre de
ressources ronaldpin pour le raccrochage
des jeunes en rupture près de vous
François Dubet bienvenue vous êtes
sociologue de l'éducation merci d'être
avec nous en face de vous Jacques
Bernard manier bonsoir vous êtes
sénateur du puit d'Ô président du groupe
d'études sur l'éducation populaire et la
culture et enfin m droite Gabrielle Val
bonsoir vous êtes pédopsychiatre
spécialiste de l'échec scolaire
bienvenue à tous alors on commence par
vos réactions à ce documentaire
Jean-Jacques Pellerin vous êtes
réalisateur vous avez aussi enseigné par
le passé est-ce que c'est cette
expérience qui vous a poussé à réaliser
un documentaire sur ce sujet non non il
y a très longtemps effectivement j'ai
enseigné dans une école de publicité
notamment mais il n'y a pas de rapport
direct entre le documentaire que j'ai pu
faire et
puis passé d'enseign pourquoi le
décrochage scolaire en fait c'est un
projet qui est né d'une interrogation
que j'avais dans les années 2009-20 donc
le projet est assez ancien entre
l'amalgame qui été
fait avec le devant le problème du
décrochage scolaire de l'absentéisme et
en même temps de la délinquence de la
sécurité publique dans ces
années-là il y avait le désir de punir
les familles en fait qui avait un enfant
décrocheur dans la mesure où la part de
cet enfant en cause était supprimée au
niveau des allocation familiale en tout
cas il y avait cette volonté là donc
d'être répressive et culpabilisante à
l'égard des familles et je pensais que
la question du décrochage releva d'un
processus au long terme avec des
interactions entre l'élève la famille et
l'école et que c'était quelque chose de
compliqué de complexe qu'on ne pouvait
pas caricaturer ou instrumentaliser
cette questionl dans la mesure où
derrière le décrochage il y a toujours
beaucoup de souffrance h ce que ce que
vous souhaitiez montrer c'est le côté
inégalitaire du système alors je me suis
intéressé justement à l'institution
scolaire qui d'un côté va mettre en
place une pédagogie qui fait qui
participe à un certain urgentisme avec
des dispositifs de remédiation et puis
de l'autre côté une une école qui classe
qui élimine pour fabriquer au final une
petite élite alors vous avez un
parti-prix assez fort hein votre propos
est très clair vous estimez que l'école
aujourd'hui ne remplit plus son rôle
l'école ne remplit plus sa sa mission il
y a beaucoup d'élèves pour qui ce qui
est enseigné n'a aucun sens en fait ne
fait plus sens et puis c'est une école
qui dysfonctionne avec un avec une bon
qui tout cela est pointé d'ailleurs par
les enquêtes PISA qui sont des enquêtes
de l'OCDE effectivement il y a une masse
d'élèves qui ont en échec de façon
extrêmement importante les familles les
enseignants les élèves ont vu votre
documentaire comment ils ont réagi
écoutez le le documentaire a été projeté
lors d'une avant-première en fait au
cinéma et donc devant un grand nombre
d'enseignants qui était présent ce
jour-là il se trouve que il n'y a pas eu
de de réaction négative qui relevait
d'une animosité à l'égard du
documentaire non il y a eu un débat
plutôt serein dans la mesure où il y a
des enseignants qui ne se sentent pas
bien dans ce système scolaire il y a des
enseignants effectivement conservateurs
qui ne veulent pas que les choses
changent qui rêvent d'un d'or qui
peut-être n'a jamais existé il y a il y
a des enseignants décrocheurs donc qui
sont pointés avec oui c'est il y a pas
que les élèves qui décrochent Aignant
tout à fait et puis il y a des
enseignants finalement qui ont qui sont
des résistants à l'intérieur du système
soit à titre individuel ou dans des
mouvements pédagogiques ça existe aussi
et qui pensent que les jeunes ont des
capacités ont un potentiel qu'il faut
lutter contre le fatalisme en
l'occurrence de l'échec qu'est-ce qui
vous a apporté ce documentaire votre
regard a évolué vous êtes parti avec une
thèse de départ ou plutôt un regard
assez ouvert
en fait oui le projet s'est transformé
parce que au départ le le documentaire
devait uniquement concerner les
dispositif de remédiation donc en fait
il sont des activités de soutien un peu
sophistiqué et de fil en aiguille je me
suis aperçu que il y avait une espèce
d'absurdité à mettre en place des
dispositifs de remédiation d'une part et
de l'autre côté à continuer à avoir une
école qui dysfonctionne autant h vos
réactions à ce documentaire Bernard
jedre mais moi j'ai aimé le documentaire
parce que il donne la parole à des
jeunes je trouve que quand l'histoire de
l'école croise les histoires singulières
des jeunes c'est toujours intéressant et
c'est rarement fait par contre il y a
des moments où le documentaire m'a un
peu laissé sur ma fin il m'a laissé sur
ma fin quand j'ai eu le sentiment que
s'il creusait assez fort le sillon de la
causalité pourquoi décroche-t-il et si
jamais on arrive à répondre à cette
question bien peut-être qu'on pourra
s'emparer du problème et faire qu'il
décroche point euh mais ça me paraissait
une question déjà un peu datée
aujourd'hui on en est déjà à se poser la
question comment les raccrocher mais les
raccrocher pas simplement parce qu'ils
ont décroché pas simplement parce qu'ils
sont décrocheurs vous parliez tout à
l'heure des décrocheurs je crois qu'un
des grands malentendus de l'école et
c'est là-dessus qu'on bosse aujourd'hui
c'est que le mot décrocheur n'est pas
juste décrocher ça voudrait dire qu'ils
ont été accrochés or un grand nombre des
jeunes qui décrochent aujourd'hui sont
des jeunes qui n'ont jamais été accroché
donc la question c'est comment les
accrocher et cette questionl elle pose
la question mais très clairement du sens
et je trouve que la question du sens
n'est pas assez présente dans le film on
va y revenir François Dubé non moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé le le le film parce que
d'une certaine manière il casse l'idée
d'une catégorie
homogène on fait on fait une sorte de
grand groupe les élèves décrocheur
effectivement potentiellement
délinquant famille difficile et cetera
et on sort quand même de cette affaire
puisque on sait qu'il y a des élèves qui
décrochent dans ces situations mais
qu'il y a de de potentiellement bons
élèves qui ne porte plus l'école euh
j'ai même connu des élèves qui étaient
qui avaient de la haine à l'égard de
l'école et et cette diversité quand même
il faut il faut la la la la la montrer
parce qu'autrement on va fabriquer comme
d'habitude des fantômes sur lesquels on
va agir évidemment de manière inefficace
ce que j'ai un peu regretté mais c'est
ce sont des reproches évidemment absurde
c'est qu'il y a une forme de décrochage
à laquelle moi j'étais très sensible
comme chercheur ce sont des élèves qui
qui décroche sans qu'on le voit qui sont
à l'intérieur du système qui ne posent
pas l'ombre d'un problème et dont les
enseignants vous disent dont les élèves
même disent j'attends que ça passe ça ne
m'intéresse pas je ne dérange personne
et j'ai même vu des élèves dire à les
enseignants écoutez je ne vous dérange
pas soyez gentil ne me dérange pas
dérange pas non plus et très souvent
d'ailleurs les enseignants assez
rationnellement acceptent au fond ça
rend la vie plus paisible et ça c'est un
peu tragique j'ajoute que vous n'avez
pas percé un segment plus plus plus âgé
du décrochage qui moi comme
universitaire me pose beaucoup de
problèmes quand j'observe que dans
certains segments de l'Université de
masse la moitié des étudiants ont
disparu euh au mois au mois de janvier
et donc qu'il ne travaillent pas qu'il
n'étudi pas et qu'ils ont en réalité
décroché avec évidemment ce sentiment
très profond de perdre son temps de ne
rien valoir de per confiance ça n'est
pas tragique ça ne se voit pas ça ne met
pas le feu au cité donc on en parle
moins mais pour moi c'est un problème et
alors qui statistiquement écrase les
catégories que nous avons en tête he
Jacques Bernard man oui ce documentaire
montre bien le enfin essaie de montrer
le rôle de l'école dans la société que
nous vivons en définitive et qui est
beaucoup plus diverse et beaucoup plus
compliqué que celle que l'on pouvait
connaître quand on notamment à l'époque
de Jul ferry au début du 19e siècle mais
aussi il y a seulement quelques dizaines
d'années euh c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
la tâche des enseignants est plus
compliquée celle des familles est aussi
plus diverse et compliqué et on
s'aperçoit que le décrochage scolaire
puisque c'est ainsi qu'on l'appelle
correspond souvent à une erreur
d'orientation des élèves ou à une
difficulté d'orientation des élèves et
un problème d'évaluation des élèves donc
il y a là et puis aussi quelquefois une
formation des enseignants et des des
gens qui travaillent dans les écoles
dont on à qui on demande de plus en plus
de choses la psychologie de la
sociologie de la capacité à savoir à
connaître l'élève l'enfant dans dans sa
son intégralité sa totalité et c'est
vrai que ça dépasse un peu le métier
d'enseignant tel qu'il avait été défini
il y a très longtemps et c'est pour ça
que aujourd'hui il faut que la formation
des enseignants suivent on va y revenir
aussi Gabriel Val vous partagez ce point
de vue je rappelle vous êtes
pédopsychiatre vous voyez ces ces élèves
alors je les vois évidemment comme on
peut les voir dans un bureau des
plaintes parce que en général quand
quand on consulte un pédopsie pour des
motifs scolaires c'est c'est
naturellement pas pour dresser des
louanges sur le l'éducation nationale
alors moi j'ai été plutôt sensible la
dimension sociale parce que le décor
c'est quand même un lycée d'enseignement
professionnel et très très visuellement
même si tout est suggéré on a le
sentiment quand même qu'un établissement
d'enseignement professionnel aujourd'hui
c'est un
ghetto social un ghetto scolaire un
getetto même socio-ethnique donc il y a
véritablement un problème de
d'orientation et on pourrait presque se
se consoler de ce que cette orientation
se base sur des critères olaire mais
c'est pas vrai par exemple on a fait des
études pour comparer le désir qui est
souvent et auquel on accède souvent de
demande de passage en seconde générale à
niveau égal 80 % des enfants de cadre
s'offrent la seconde générale 20 % des
ouvriers seulement donc le le donc un
décrocheur a forcément un contexte
social alors là on n'est pas au
décrochage là pour l'instant on est à
l'orientation contrainte j'entends
souvent le mot subi pour moi elle est
même pas subi elle est véritable
contrainte qu'il y a de la souffrance
souvent dans les orientations et
l'orientation contrainte c'est l'une des
principales causes du décrochage donc en
fabriquant des lycées professionnels qui
ne sont pas des lieux de désir mais des
lieux de contrainte on fabrique le
décrochage ça c'est vraiment un aspect
auquel j'ai été particulièrement
sensible alors vous effectivement votre
documentaire contextualise très bien
socialement ses élèves ça se passe mais
concrètement un décrocheur qu'est-ce
qu'un décrocheur de qui on parle en fait
Bernard je mais c'est une question très
épineuse que vous posez il y a pas de
typologie du décrocheur c'est
multifactoriel le décrochage et la
configuration du décrocheur elle est
dans toutes les couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel je vais vous donner un
exemple tout bête qui n'est pas
anecdotique quand le klept est né le
collège lycée liter portous qui
accueille que des jeunes en ruptures
scolaire à Grenoble il est né en 2000 3
ans après un journal qui normalement ne
s'adresse que aux enseignants de
l'éducation nationale puisque c'est
le journal de leur sécurité sociale la
mgenen euh a fait un dossier de 5 pages
sur le klept on dit très souvent en tout
cas c'est comme ça que l'image se
construit que ceux qui sont les moins
sujets à l'échec scolaire et au
décrochage scolaire sont les enfants
d'enseignants après la pararution de ce
numéro qui était essentiellement lu par
des enseignants le standard du klep a
explosé donc c'est bien pour dire que le
décrochage n'est pas simplement dans les
quartier que vous avez un peu montré ou
ou même avec cette tendance à croire
qu'il serait ethnique et cetera François
rappelait tout à l'heure il a tout à
fait raison qu'il y a une marge euh
c'est sûr que c'est une marge c'est pas
le cœur du décrochage mais il y a une
marge non négligeable d'élèves à peu
près 15 % dans l'effectif du club depuis
15 ans qu'il existe qui sont des
décrocheurs qui étaient mais tout à fait
à l'aise par rapport à la restitution
des savoirs enseignés qui avaient des
notes tout à fait correctes mais qui ne
supportaient pas l'infantilisation dont
ils étaient victimes au sein de la
structure scolaire il ne se sentaiit pas
bien au sein de l'école tout à fait ils
avaient l'impression que la
normalisation scolaire les infantilisait
donc les les motifs de décrochages sont
extrêmement variés he et et du coup
trouver le décrocheur c'est très
compliqué par contre ce que je peux
répondre quand même à votre question
parce que c'est une vraie question c'est
que lorsqu'on superpose l'ensemble des
monographies qu'on a faites et réalisé
depuis maintenant presque 20 ans avec
ses décrocheur il y a quand même des
noyaux durs qui apparaissent et qui
nourrissent alors de manière constante
le processus de décrochage quel que soit
l'origine du décrocheur Gabriel vous
êtes d'accord avec oui et non je suis
d'accord pour l'essentiel mais je
voudrais préciser un point les les
études internationales alors on est
obligé évidemment de d'aller au-delà de
la France parce qu'en France il y a très
peu d'études sérieuses sur le sujet
montre que un seul facteur est très
rarement à l'origine d'un décrochage
c'est l'effet cumulatif c'est l'effet
d'addition et il y a trois grands
registres il y a les problèmes
individuels les problèmes sociaux et les
problèmes scolaires voilà et donc il y a
véritablement un certain nombre de
données médicales et psychologiques là
je je reviens un peu à ma spécialist
qui peuvent être considérés comme étant
à l'origine du décrochage par exemple
les troubles de la tension par exemple
la dépression c'est peut-être pour ça
que certaines personnes sont invisibles
et décrochent soudainement mais une
dépression c'est pas c'est pas
nécessairement visible en tout
cascience non plus ces â par exemple les
des difficultés aussi bêtes que par
exemple la dyslexie la dysorthographie
lorsqu'elle n'est pas corriger et cetera
et cetera donc vous avez un noyau de
difficulté individuelle comportemental
ou instrumental et là-dessus vous
ajoutez une difficulté sociale un manque
d'engagement parental des difficultés
familiales affectives et un problème
social et vous avez un décrocheur en
puissance alors il y a évidemment des
exceptions il y a des décrocheurs qui
n'ont pas de problème individuel il des
crocheurs qui n'ont pas de problèmes
sociaux mais très globalement le le
profil pour répondre à votre question
c'est quelqu'un qui cumule qui
additionne un certain nombre de
difficultés vous êtes d'accord
Jean-Jacques pin avec ces anal a des
choses il me semble juste en fait ce que
j'ai voulu montrer dans le film c'est la
question centrale du film c'est comment
l'école internalise entre ses murs les
inégalités sociales et pour cela vous en
avez parlé un peu il est vrai que le
lycée professionnel est un lieu de
relégation alors il y a des exceptions
évidemment mais d'ailleurs la
conseillère principale d'éducation en
parle très souvent on et les mamans
aussi d'ailleurs on vous met là et puis
débrouillez-vous disent-t-elles les
mamans hein alors il faut dire tous les
éléments du dossier il est vrai qu'il y
a des enfants qui ont développé un grand
ressentiment vis-à-vis du du collège et
qui peuvent également se reconstruire au
lycée professionnel dans la mesure où il
y a des enseignants qui ont les mêmes
origines sociales parfois que les
enfants qu'ils accueillent et qui
eux-mêmes vont innover mettre en place
des des projets c'est vrai mais en même
temps quand on pose la question aux
enseignants et là c'est c'est très
intéressant y compris aux enseignants
qui qui sont dans les filières du lycée
professionnel ils ne mettent pas leurs
enfants au lycée professionnel parce que
très souvent quand un enfant quand un
jeune sort du lycée professionnel avec
un bac pro en
poche l'emploi auquel il s'attendait
n'est pas au rendez-vous normalement les
enfants les jeunes qui sont en lycée
professionnel doivent pouvoir être aptes
à à occuper un emploi hautement qualifié
François Dubet oui il faudrait se poser
la question de savoir euh pourquoi ça
nous pourquoi ça nous pose un problème
parce que dans du temps formidable de la
vieille école de de de la République qui
fait verser à beaucoup de Français des
torents de larmes nostalgiques le
décrochage scolaire faisait partie de la
vie scolaire banale les cancres d'orant
au fond de la classe ne scandalisaient
personne les les instituteurs ne
présentaient pas un nombre considérable
d'élèves au certificat d'études pour que
les statistiques de l'école soient
bonnes les filles étaient étaient
invitées à chercher un mari et les
garçons savaient qu'ils auraient du
boulot dans l'agriculture sans diplôme
et cetera ce qui a complètement changé
au fond il y avait même un poème qu'on
apprenait à l'école qui est une sorte de
de de de de chose incroyable où on
faisait où on enchantait le cancre parce
qu'au fond c'était pas tragique CIT une
manière un peu étrange et perverse quand
même à mon avis de de de d'intégrer le
cancre bon aujourd'hui on est dans une
société où chacun a parfaitement compris
que la carrière scolaire d'un élève va
déterminer pour l'essentiel son parcours
social et donc l'échec scolaire est
devenu une vraie pathologie d'abord un
enseignant ne peut plus supporter
d'avoir d'élèves même si c'est une
machine à trier on le sait tous mais un
élève qui qui ne suit pas ça lui pose un
problème au fond quasi de de conscience
bon parce qu'il a le devoir de faire
RÉIR tout le monde les parents sont dans
un état de panique absolu tout le monde
a parfaitement compris C faaire et le
problème ne cesse de monter ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que quand on veut
compter les les décrocheurs on peut
avoir des chiffres qui vont du simple au
triple si je considère qu'un décrocheur
c'est quelqu'un qui est sorti du collège
sans diplôme j'anné 150000 si je
considère qu'un décrocheur c'est
quelqu'un donc je ne sais pas ce qu'il
fait et là il y en a beaucoup plus que
150000 un quelqu'un qui a 18 ans donc je
peux dire qui ne travaille pas qui n'est
pas en formation qui n'est pas à l'école
qui n'est pas étiqueté dealur
professionnel par la police ça en fait
quand même quel quelques et C donc on
est dans dans dans dans dans dans
quelque chose qui est le
dysfonctionnement de l'école bien
évidemment mais aussi une sorte de
crispation du lien école emploi qui fait
que c'est devenu tragique pour un élève
aujourd'hui comprendre à 17 ans que
l'école c'est pas fait pour lui ça n'est
pas simplement est-ce qu'il le comprend
vraiment à à 17 ans que j'allais vous
dire qu même comprend c'est qu'on
décroche pas du jour au lendemain c'est
que c'est un phénomène long comment se
fait-il il le comprend très très vite
avant d'après les les travaux que que
nous avons fait que j'ai fait il le
comprend très très vite d'abord parce
que ses copains lui font pas de cadeau
c'est pas facile de décrocher on est
tout seul pendant l'élève le le comprend
mais le corps enseignant comment se
fait-il qu'on ne repère pas euh un
décrocheur dans dans les plus petites
classes et d'ailleurs jacesbernard
j'allais vous en parler
puisqueaujourd'hui le ministère axe sur
l'école primaire les États-Unis ont
travailler là-dessus depuis les années
70 80 où ils estiment que ça se passe
quand même beaucoup au au niveau l'école
primaire parfois au CP tout à fait même
parfois dans les premières années de la
scolarisation des enfants on a à se
préoccuper de savoir la façon dont
l'enfant est géré par le milieu scolaire
et comment il s'adapte au milieu
scolaire c'est pour cela qu'il faut pas
aller trop vite en maternel on s'était
mis à vouloir apprendre à lire et à
écrire quasiment aux enfants en grande
section de maternel on vient de s'en
apercevoir et au Conseil supérieur des
programmes on est en train de réorenter
ces choseslà en disant qu'il faut quand
même laisser ne pas primar la maternelle
parce que beaucoup de choses se jouent
dès la maternelle ensuite à l'école
élémentaire il y a certainement des
programmes qui ne sont pas adaptés à la
maturité actuelle des enfants il faut
certainement les les revoir on rentrer
dans l'aire du numérique il peut-être
pas nécessaire de vouloir apprendre la
racine carrée en cours moyen Dee année
en définitive pas aujourd'hui il y a
deux fois moins d'heur de français
enseignés au primairire qu'au début du
siècle oui parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'autres matières il y a beaucoup
d'autres matières et heureusement c'est
la richesse de l'enseignement et puis le
français malheureusement
est pas tout à fait d'accord bah c'estut
on peuttre pas on peut rajouter des
matières mais garder un un nombre d' je
suis d'accord d'apprendre beaucoup plus
de choses d'abord au début du siècle on
avait une obsession de l'orthographe qui
était quasiment maladie et puis il faut
quand même rappeler en ces temps de de
rythme scolaire que le temps scolaire
c'est considérablement réduit oui nous
préférons les loisirs très largement au
temps scolaire donc oui mais les pays
qui réussissent ils ont pas forcément
plus d'heur de classe que nous il il les
utiliseent nement HM alors je vais
remercier Jean-Jacques pèlerin d'avoir
réalisé ce documentaire et d'être venu
nous voir on vient de le dire à l'école
il y a pas que les élèves qui décrochent
mais les profs aussi sont en difficulté
je voudrais qu'on récoute un extrait du
documentaire il y a aussi des profs qui
sont en échec scolaire euxmême les profs
sont des hommes et des femmes à
partentières les enfants aussi et il se
rend compte chacun avec leurs
difficultés et les difficultés explose
en cours un prof qui déprime ou qui
décroche est pas plus suivi qu'un enfant
qui décroche parce qu'il y a pas
d'écoute il y a de l'écoute nulle part
dans le fait un prof qui décroche au
pire on lui demande gentiment de se
mettre en arrêt de travail et s'il veut
pas bah les élèves subissent c'est tout
doit rentrer dans un moule que
l'éducation nationale a créé mais ce
moul il n'existe pas c'est un leure ce
truc là ça existe pas du tout mais en
aucun cas ils se remettent en question
c'est jamais eux où il y a des failles
c'est obligatoirement la famille et
l'histoire de l'enfant et à mes yeux
c'est trop facile il poent du doigt sur
un truc pour se dédoiner eux bon c'est
un témoignage fort dur avec les
enseignants mais ça pose cette question
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la formation des
enseignants est
insuffisante moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé
sur la mise en place des écoles
supérieures des professurats et de
l'éducation Fame qui sont mis en place
par le fondation de l'école et qui
effectivement on la vocation de corriger
ce qui a été abandonné pendant les 10
dernières années c'est-à-dire la
capacité des enseignants de pouvoir all
voir comment on enseigne parce que
aujourd'hui il suffit pas d'être dans la
théorie il faut aussi dans la pratique
c'est ce qu'on faisait un peu à l'École
normale on le faisait même beaucoup mais
pas aussi longtemps qu'il le faudrait et
on avait l'habitude de travailler à la
fois devant des élèves
d'être contrôlé vérifié par ceux qui
étaient censé être des pédagogues et
savoirfire la classe et ensuite on
pouvait revenir pour discuter des
failles des difficultés et des problèmes
et c'est là je pense qu'on peut
sécuriser la façon de d'apprendre le
métier d'enseignant et je pense que les
esps aujourd'hui vont correspondre
puisqueon a on est aujourd'hui en 2e
année de ce que sont les esps on a des
gens qui vont être à la fois pendant 12h
pendant 9h sur le terrain et 9h pour ce
qui concerne l'enseignement secondaire
et et 12h et 12h pour les les
professeurs des écoles quelle est la
différence réelle avec les IUFM en fait
est-ce que c'est pas un retour en fait
non les ufm il étaient en train de
perdre complètement la capacité à aller
sur le terrain travailler pendant le
temps qu'il le faut pendant quelques
semaines on le faisait pour des stages
en situation mais aujourd'hui pendant
toute une année l'année de Master 2e
année on va envoyer les gens faire leur
formation devant des élèves en même
temps qu'ils vont revenir à l'université
enfin à l'école supérieure qui est une
partie de l'université pour pouvoir à la
fois théoriser à la fois
dans la discipline et à la fois être
dans la pratique franis dub non je
trouve que que les SP c'est mieux que
rien et c'est peut-être un peu mieux que
les ufm mais je crois qu'on n' pas
véritablement pris le virage d'une
formation professionnelle je le dis
d'ailleurs je je vous l'avais dit une
fois je je crois que la formation
professionnelle ça ça on en a de bons
exemples quand on veut faire un ur il
rentre dans une école d'ingénieur à bac
+ 1 ou Bac + 2 il passe 5 ans il apprend
un
métier nous avons une image du métier
enseignant qui reste le métier d'un
clair je fais une licence puis je fais
une maîtrise et puis je me demande ce
que je pourrais
faireateur faut plus 5 et ensuite on
peut accéder ce qu' a ce qu' a ce qui a
plusieurs défauts le premier c'est
qu'évidemment l'image qu'on a c'est
quand même pas celle de métier qu'on
apprend précocement le deuxème défaut
c'est que on élève socialement le niveau
de recrute just plus vous recrutez tard
plus vous recrutez dans les milieux
favorisés et pas forcément les bons
élèves parce que les meilleurs élèves
ils veulent peut-être pas être
enseignant et nous le savons un peu
dramatiquement aujourd'h il un problème
de rémunération aussi non il y a un
problème de
rémunération si vous
dites si vous dites au bon bachelier de
milieux populaire tu rentres dans une
école tu aura une bourse pendant un
moment tu sortiras avec un métier ces
bons étudiants viendront là si vous
attendez B+ 4 qu'ils auront disparu et
vous n'aurez plutôt des étudiants qui
toute chose égal par ailleurs feront un
choix que je ne dirais pas négatif mais
pas forcément enthousiaste et un peu par
défaut donc ce système a de gros défauts
parce queut nous n'avons pas
véritablement eu le le culot de dire
après tout les ingénieurs c'est un
métier les infirmières c'est un
métiery c'est une question de moyen et
puis c'est une question non c'est une
question théologique non dit Gabriel
théologique absol ique mais je sais pas
si on partage la même
théologie théologiquement je je
considère que les les enseignants
français à l'exception des instituteurs
de la 3e république qui étaient plutôt
des des prêtres laïques ont été ont été
recrutés sur leurs compétences comme des
savants c'était des savants chargés
d'enseigner à des élèves qui leur
ressemblaient ce modèle a totalement
explosé avec la massification scolaire
et il faudrait dire maintenant vous êtes
des professionnels de l'enseignement
spécialisés dans une ou deux disciplines
et et ça c'est une révolution
théologique c'est vous changez la
nature du métier Bernard ger oui dans
cette histoire de profession est-ce que
le SPE va être le bon endroit je trouve
que c'est un tout petit peu tôt pour le
dire il y avait des ambitions en tout
cas payon les a affirmé au départ de
manière un peu claire il a même parlé de
refondation c'est pas un mot neutre
refondation je pense qu'effectivement il
fallait employer un mot aussi fort que
celui-là pour donner le sentiment qu'on
avait compris l'enjeu de la question
parce que je crois que le décrochage à
partir du moment où on est à peu près
tous d'accord aujourd'hui j'avais tout à
l'heure pensé à dire néanmoins qu'il
était multifactoriel euh que c'est bien
dans l'école qu'on décroche et de
l'école qu'on décroche c'est bien le
métier d'enseignant à l'intérieur de la
classe qu'il faut réenvisager et
revisiter et moi je je dirais des choses
très très simples par rapport à ça
d'abord euh le clleub le collège lycée
litire pour tous agronom est centre de
formation continue il est est censé être
ressources en formation et il capitalise
un certain nombre de choses que son
expérimentation a permis de mettre au
jour depuis qu'il existe ça fait
maintenant 15 ans et dans les choses qui
ne sont pas miraculeuses les gens
viennent nous voir les télévisions
s'intéressent à nous viennent faire des
reportages parce qu'ils ont le sentiment
qu'on a transformé c'est un journaliste
qui enyer cette formule le plomb en or
mais non il y avait ni plomb ni or c'est
simplement des jeunes qui étaient dans
l'école avec cet énorme défaut mais ça
existe encore aujourd'hui si on y fait
pas attention en formation ça va
continuer pendant très très longtemps
c'est qu'il y a un de l'institution
l'institution croit que tout jeune qui
franchit le Porsche d'une école est
automatiquement comme ça un élève mais
une grande partie des décrocheurs une
grande partie des non accrochés sont des
jeunes qui fréquentent l'école en aucun
cas ce sont des élèves donc il faut
d'abord que ces jeunes c'est ce qui se
passe au club tout jeune qui veut
raccrocher passe par un module il faut
que ces jeunes soient en phase avec
quels sont les attentses de l'école
queles sont les règles du jeu de l'école
quels sont
les enfin il y a un tr là qui est en
train de m'échapper mais mais qui ne
sont pas dans dans l'évidence de ce qui
se transmet il y a une pédagogie de
l'exlicite qui doit permettre aux jeunes
de tirer réellement profit de ce qui se
joue pour lui à l'école et les
enseignants très souvent quand ils ont
des jeunes qui ne sont pas en phase avec
les attentes de l'école avec les règles
du jeu de l'école il rentrent assez
rapidement parce que le métier est
éprouvant on leur demande beaucoup de
choses mais très vite il rentre dans une
logique qui est puisque je ne sais pas
faire avec je vais décider de faire 100
et le décrochage ça morce avec cette
espèce de renoncement institutionnel et
qui consiste à dire que finalement il y
a des jeunes qui seraient pas fait pour
l'école ce que le klep
démontre en démonstration négative
quotidiennement par exemple Gabriel
alors moi mon sentiment c'est que les
enseignants n'ont pas de formation
pluridisciplinaire sur l'échec scolaire
et c'est vraiment pour moi le problème
numéro 1 et c'est pour ça que je parlais
un peu de d'idéologie ou théologie parce
que il y a un refus de l'approche
médicale on parle de médicalisation ou
psychologique ou psychiatrique on parle
de psychiatrisation de l'échec scolaire
et pour certains enseignants il y a une
espèce de réflexe corporatiste
enseignant et ministère il y a une
espèce de réflexe corporatiste c'est
notre affaire l'échec scolaire c'est pas
l'affaire des médecins et des psychiat
il y a pas de raison de médicaliser de
cicatriser je vais prendre un exemple
très concret il existe un trouble de
l'attention qui est de nature
biologique et pour un enseignant qui est
confronté à un enfant qui a un trouble
de la
il va en faire une affaire de maturité
de déclic de manque d'effort bref il va
transformer un symptôme biologique en
faute morale par parlez de la
dyslexie TR de l'attention c'est un
enfant sauf s'il est passionné au bout
de 2 minutes il décroche même s'il veut
faire des efforts même s'il est motivé
même s'il veut faire plaisir à sa
maîtresse et cetera et cet enfant qui
décroche il est cons on a tout un
vocabulaire de mon point de vue absurde
un vocabulaire pédagogique donc je je
commencer à le citer immaturité pas de
déclic fait néantise et cetera et cetera
et on peut tenir comme ça pendant 10 ans
et donc on peut être on peut avoir 15
ans et avoir pendant 10 ans eu des
symptômes très explicites d'un trouble
magnifiquement authentifié par toute la
littérature médicale international et
cetera et
euh lorsque j'ai écrit ce livre sur
l'échec scolaire et bien avant je me'y
suis intéressé et d'autres psychiat qui
m'ont formé il y il y a 20 ans ou 30 ans
s'y intéressé aussi il y a toujours eu à
droite comme à gauche gauche une
barrière corporatiste
idéologique de la de et donc une
impossibilité vous poin c'est les les
professeurs c'est pas les prof c'est
plutôt lesufm plutôt le ministère et par
exemple j'ai discuté avec des cabinets
de de ministres la réponse était
toujours la même c'était mais nous on
serait bien d'accord seulement dans les
ufm ils suivront pas pourquoi Bernard
Jacques bernardier non je pense que si
on donne des des formations aux
enseignants pour détecter ce genre de
difficultés ils y sert tout à fait
ouverts et capable peut-être mieux
qu'ils ne le sont aujourd'hui de
détecter ce qui n'est pas effectivement
de la Fanti de la paresse mais une
difficulté mais je pense pas que les
difficultés pathologiques soient quand
même les plus nombreuses par
rapport non si vous acceptez l'hypothèse
cumulative pour revenir à notre sujet
central et bien lorsqu'il y a parce
qu'il y a des enfants dans les familles
épouvantables dans des quartiers
terribles dans des lycées épouvantables
qui arrivent à se trouver Normal Sup oui
donc pas beaucoup il y en a pas beaucoup
mais mais néanmoins il faut qu'il y ait
il faut qu'il y ait des facteurs
individuel et comme comme il faut
s'attaquer à ce sur quoi on peut agir et
on peut plus facilement agir pour
résoudre un problème individuel et
médical que pour résoudre un problème
social on a on a évidemment pas
l'ambition autour de ce plateau de
trouver des solutions social là on est
en train de pointer pardonnez-moi je
vous donne la parole tout de suite la
formation de de du corps enseignant voà
a pouvoir identifier je peux raconter
une anecdote clinique très concrète il y
a une possibilité d'échouer scolairement
lorsqu'on a des capacités
intellectuelles haut de gamme lorsqu'on
a par exemple un Surdon ou une une
précocité intellectuel je reçois un
enfant en join qui a 14 ans et qui est
en 3e et qui est en échec scolaire il y
a un enseignant intuitif qui dit à la
psychologue il faudrait le faire tester
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il est
surdoué la psychologue répond de toute
façon c'est pas la peine de le faire
tester parce qu'avec les résultats qu'il
a il pourra jamais passer en seconde
générale la maman est employée il faut
donc qu'elle
se comment dirais- qu'elle accepte de
payer une somme relativement importante
dans le privé donc elle fait passer un
test dans le privé cotien intellectuel à
142 on l'avait orienté pour une seconde
usinage fin il est en avance par rapport
au système et donc c'est le système il
est inadapté ce serait compliqué
expliquer mais en gros pour simplifier
les les précoces intellectuellement ont
une incapacité d'apprendre s'il n'y a
pas de l'émotion s'il n'y a pas de la
passion donc quand ils sont en classe et
qu'on leur raconte si je dire
l'ordinaire des cours bah ils se ferment
et donc ils peuvent complètement
décrocher et ca l'ennui et cetera donc
je je vais jusqu'au bout vous allez voir
le le reste est j'espère aussi
passionnant que le début donc cette dame
évidemment va très légitimement voir le
principal du collège la principale dans
la circonstance qui lui répond
textuellement un oui peut-être à propos
du 142 deuxièmement de toute façon dans
mon établissement on ne redouble pas
donc si on si il doit refaire une
troisième ce sera dans un autre
établissement et je vous préviens ce
sera peut-être à 2h de transport de
votre domicile et s'il passe en seconde
générale s'il échoue au premier mois on
le mettra dans un lycée professionnel
degré ou de force sans qu'il puisse
choisir son lieu ni sa for
elle a accepté la seconde usinage elle
me raconte ça
évidemment je suis enfin le mot
indignation est faible j'espère que vous
la partagez voilà un exemple concret
alors ce jeune homme là il passera
finalement en seconde générale où il
redoublera je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas j'ai convaincu la mère de refuser
absolument cette orientation voilà
typiquement on a une famille socialement
favorisée évidemment qu' refuse cette
orientation a des enseignants qui sont
capables de proposer poser un bilan
psychologique lorsqu'il y a un problème
et cetera et cetera alors il faut vous
êtes en train de pore du Doig la
difficulté entre le système scolaire et
les parents et justement bah les parents
ils sont en colère ils sont souvent
dépassés je voudrais que on réécoute
cette MRE d'élève on leur donne une
toute petite place des parents toute
petite l'école veut prendre la place des
familles voilà c'est pas une méfiance
ils veut prendre la place des familles
c'est tout ils s'imposent c'està dire
qu'ils prennent les décisions à votre
place ils pensent à votre place il
trouvent que c'est mieux à votre place
alors bah je vais vous dire une chose
quand il tombe sur un couple
effectivement de parents euh avec la
meilleure volonté du monde effectivement
qui sont pas trop instruits qui parlent
pas la langue française ils prennent des
décisions à leur place donc moi
effectivement avec moi ils sont tombés
sur un os hein parce que moi ils font
pas ce qu'ils veulent de ma gamine au
moment où il le décide on là on sent la
colère hein d'une mère d'élèv est-ce que
les parents décident euh les pardon les
les professeurs décident à la place des
parents Bernard ger je ne sais pas je ne
crois pas mais je n'ai pas du tout envie
de dire que la dame qui parle d'un vécu
qui a l'air d'être être encore très
chaud et très douloureux se trompe sur
son sa perception mais je crois pas que
dans l'éducation nationale non
l'institution décide à à la place des
parents et si c'était le cas même
marginalement ça serait effectivement
grave puisque je rappelle quand même
qu'une des fonctions principales de
l'école c'est de d'obtenir
l'émancipation de l'enfant et
l'émancipation de l'enfant
malheureusement pour les familles elle
inclut y compris la famille c'estd
s'émancipé y compris par rapport à sa
famille sans sans désigner de
culpabilité mais quelle est la la la
responsabilité des parents dans l'échec
scolaire c'està-dire que un il faut
délimiter le rôle de chacun donc les
élèves les parents le le système renez
vous revenez à mon propos initial
c'estàdire que quand on est dans la
causalité on on met en cause il faut
trouver un coupable je suis pas d'accord
avec cette approche du problème qui
consiste à trouver un coupable de la
même manière que je ne suis pas d'accord
à penser que c'est des problèmes
médicaux qui expliquent le classement de
la France dans les tests de PISA pas du
tout je crois que le décrochage avec
l'envergure qu'il a pose d'autres
questions que des questions simplement
médicales et je crois qu'effectivement
le enseignant a drôlement raison de se
méfier d'une médicalisation à outrance
pas de la médicalisation mais à outrance
des problèmes scolaires je crois
vraiment de la même manière que je crois
que le corps enseignant a raison d'être
extrêmement vigilant sur les démarches
préventives prédictives repérage qui
fait qu'à force de repérer et de repérer
très tôt quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument trouver parce que sinon en
tant que professionnel on aura manqué le
système d'alerte par rapport à ce
phénomène lourd qui est aujourd'hui le
décrochage à force d'être dans cette
logique prédictive on induit le
prédictif est inducteur donc il faut y
aller quand même avec un tout petit peu
de prudence par rapport à la
médicalisation et il y a des diagnostics
médicaux comme des diagnostics scolair
d'ailleurs qui se sont avérés dans la
durée assez infficace jacqu Bernard oui
je crois qu'il faut pas procéder par
test pour pouvoir savoir très tôt ce que
les gamins sont capables de faire ou pas
faire il y a toute une stratégie à
monter pour éviter justement qu'il y ait
aussi un aussi grand nombre de
dégrocheurs mais je pense que il y aura
malheureusement toujours des des enfants
comm vous disiez qui ont une forme
d'inadaptation et qui est difficile à
détecter mais il y a aussi si on fait
pas de test elle sera très difficile à
détecter il s'agit pas de faire passer
des testes à tout le monde mais on peut
quand même faire passer un bilan
médico-psychologique à des enfants qui
sont en échec scolaire on peut avoir un
enfant inadapté mais le système peut
être inadapté à détecte un handicap à ce
momentl on a des des professionnels dans
l'éducation nationale qui peuvent
détecter un handicap qui peut être
corrigé par du soutien par exemple la
dyslexie la dysorthophonie et choses
comme cela on les détecte il y a des
personnels il y a des gens qui sont
formés pour travailler avec l'élève en
d'une manière personnalisée pour lutter
contre c ces handicaps
là les parents parents on voit he dans
le documentaire et puis souvent ça
revient que les parents son sont un peu
pés dans tout parents ils oublient
souvent qu'ils ont un rôle fondamental
dans l'éducation de les enfants on le
sait quand on est enseigné pendant de
nombreuses années on voit bien qu'il y a
des familles qui s'occupent bien de
leurs enfants d'autres s'occupent moins
bien et d'autres qui c'est un métier qui
ne s'apprend pas parents c'est terrible
mais le rôle de l'école c'est quand même
de s'occuper des enfants dont elle a la
charge et et c'est une situation qui est
très très particulière à la France que
celle de ce procès croisé les parents de
de ce film qui ne sont pas contents font
le procès des enseignants et on sait que
les enseignants font le procès des
parents chacun considérant parce que
comme c'est insupportable cette histoire
d'échec scolaire il faut absolument se
débarrasser de la faute et alors si
c'était Dieu c'est-à-dire la médecine et
la biologie ça serait parfait mais ça
sera les parents ça sera les enseignants
et cetera je je je crois qu'il y a un
problème qui se pose de toute façon dans
dans dans dans dans ces histoires c'est
qu'on a une école incroyablement
normative c'est-à-dire que le modèle que
l'on a du fonctionnement d'un élève y
compris dans les très petites classes
est un modèle très rigide il doit il
doit savoir lire à cet âge il doit
savoir faire ça à cette âge doit se
comporter de cette manière et donc vous
avez toujours dans un groupe scolaire
des élèves au fond trop trop inattentif
trop intelligent trop actif et qui tout
de suite rentre dans dans des catégories
d'exclusion je crois que la formation
des maîtres ne règlerait pas tout mais
elle pourrait apprendre cet art
extrêmement difficile de faire la classe
ensemble à des élèves qui sont pas
exactement exactement les mêmes que
recherchent les enseignants et ils ont
bien raison il recherchent les bons
lycées pourquoi on recherche les bons
lycées parce que dans les bons lycées le
tri a été tellement radical au départ
qu'on a une sorte de clonage et que même
ceux qui décrochent le font pas
remarquer donc on est à peu près
tranquille mais le reste du temps on est
on est devant une diversité de cas
concrètement parce que on on avance on
arrive bientôt au terme du débat
qu'est-ce qu'on peut préconiser de
concret pour sortir parce que c'était
une promesse de campagne de François
Hollande diviser les décrocheurs par
deux bon il va rester à peu près 2 ans
avant la fin du quinena c'est mal parti
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut il y
a des systèmes qui fonctionnent je moi
je dirais alors bon quand on regarde les
données internationales c'est très
compliqué parce qu'on sait pas trop ce
qu'on mesure la France aurait à peu près
deux fois plus de décrocheur que ne le
supposerait h estôt dans
décrochageolaire euh ceci étant je je
crois qu'il faut agir sur le système et
sortir de cette de de de de ce mécanisme
infernal que nous avons qui consiste à
dire notre école dysfonctionne créons à
côté des structures sans cesse qui vont
récupér il faut arriver à changer le
fonctionnement de la classe ça me
paraîit essentiel d'accord mais on a
dans le débat beaucoup ENF pas fait le
procès mais stigmatiser le lycée
professionnel et je crois qu'il y a là
une ressource possible pour l'avenir de
valoriser la ce que peut être le lycée
professionnel moi j'ai dans dans mon
département des licées professionnels
qui sont très attractifs notamment celui
de l'aéronautique par exemple et qui
aujourd'hui attirent il y a 800
candidats pour
15chis d'acord les lycées professionnels
aujourd'hui ils ont des débouchés pour
la plupart de ceux que je connais qui
apportent du travail plus facilement que
ceux qui peuvent être aller pendant 2
années ou 3 années en université il faut
valoriser cela et on dit toujours il
faut valoriser le travail manuel mais
personne effectivement att attendez
parce que on arrive au ter du débat
bernardre Gabriel Val vous terminez
minutes je voudrais dire donc puisque
vous demandiez des choses très concrètes
premièrement il faudrait que par le
biais de la formation on donne un statut
à l'erreur que l'enfant puisse se
tromper dans le cours de son
apprentissage sans que ça soit
immédiatement transformé en lacune
deuxièmement comme le disait il y a 2
minutes François Dubet il faudrait que
la singularité des jeunes puisse exister
à l'école puisse s'exprimer et qu'on ne
transforme pas immédiatement toute
différence en handicap il faudrait que
les profs apprennent à ne pas être des
démures à penser que tout dépend d'eux
et dépend de seul qu'ils acceptent
l'idée de travailler en équipe voilà
c'est c'est des choses un peu fortes qui
permettrait peut-être de changer en
partie la donne et il faudrait surtout
puisque vous avez parlé du lycée
professionnel qu'on cesse de tomber en
lycée professionnel avec ce que ça peut
avoir comme chute on choix et on déchoix
mais qu'on y entre en lycée
professionnel et qu'on ait des raisons
d'y entrer je rappelle je m'arrêterai
c'est pas une anecdote que lorsque merux
en 1999 a dépouillé la consultation
nationale des lycées les lycéens
professionnels qui avaient répondu
massivement à cette consultation se
demandaient pourquoi ils étaient les
seuls du système à ne pas bénéficier
d'un enseignement de la
philosophie comme il me reste peu de
temps donc je vais aller vite il
faudrait que la France se débarrasse de
philosophie inspirée de Merieux ou de
bourdieux qu'elle ne vivent plus en
autarxie qu'elle s'ouvre aux études
internationales qui montrent que le
décrochage scolaire peut être en lien
direct et étroit avec l'échec scolaire
et que l'échec scolaire est souvent en
cause avec non pas des catégories mais
des TR trouble non pas des
catégorisations mais des souffrances et
donc je pense que la médecine a son
petit mot à
dire est souvent exclu au système merci
à tous d'êt venu sur ce plateau la
semaine prochaine vous accueillerez
Laurent Bazin pour son premier débat sur
la chaîne consacré au populisme moi je
vous retrouve dans 15 jours nous
parlerons du Vatican à très vite sur
Public
[Musique]
Sénat
I